[Music]
hey everyone my name is Karina and I'm
an AI researcher at open AI before that
I worked at antarik for about two years
working on cloud so today I would love
to chat more about what kind of scaling
paradigms that has happened in the past
two to four years in AI research and how
those paradigms unlocked New Frontier
product research I'm also going to share
some of the vignettes from some of the
lessons learned by developing claw and
Chach PT products some design challenges
and lessons um and how do I think about
the future of Agents as they become from
collaborators to co innovators um in the
future I would also love to invite you
to engage um in the conversation so I'd
be more than happy to answer some of the
questions at the
end cool
so not sure if probably the majority of
you know this but I think there are two
scaling paradigms that Hasen happened in
AI research over the past few years the
first Paradigm is the next token
production and you might have heard this
as called
pre-training and what's really amazing
about the next token prediction is that
it's a World building machine the model
learns to understand the World by
predicting the next word and I think
fundamentally if you think about it
this is happening because certain
sequence is caused by initial action and
this is irreversible and so the model
learns some of the physics of the world
to understand and the token can be
anything right the tokens that we pre-
chained are strings words pixels it
could be
anything and so to predict what will
happen next the model needs to
understand how the world works and this
is why
raining worked and so you can imagine
the next token prediction is the massive
multitask
learning and what's amazing about this
is that during prating some tasks are
really easy to learn such as translation
right like the word boarding in French
is the model also learns a lot about the
world the capital of France is Paris and
because some of the information is much
more present on the internet and in some
of the knowledge artifacts the model has
much easier time to learn this but
actually the reason why compute is so
important and scaling Compu in the
paining stage is so so important is
because there is a new class there is a
class of tasks that is really really
hard to learn and for example the model
learns a lot about the physics it learns
so much about the problem solving
generation and The Logical Expressions
it learns some of the spal reasoning
although it's not
perfect um but we getting to the
complexity of the tasks such as math
when the model has to compute this
number during the next token prediction
is actually really high so that's why
you need Chain of Thought or might spend
more compute on the Chain of Thought
to help the model to reason through more
computational such tasks another class
of tasks that I was thinking a lot about
is creative writing it's actually really
really hard and the reason why it's so
hard for the model is because you know
you can predict very nicely the style of
the writing but a lot of the creative
writing is actually World building and
storytelling and the plot and it's much
much easier for the model to make a
mistake for the next token prediction in
such a way where it will completely
deteriorate the plot coherence which is
really important for the stories and
this is an open-ended like research
problem um creative writing in itself
and the reason why it's because it's
really really hard to measure what is a
good creative writing what is not a
creative writing and obviously we would
love for the models to invent new forms
of writing and be extremely creative in
their generation s but this is actually
one of the hardest AI research problems
today is um how do we make models to
like write novels and have
coherent stories over the long course of
the period of
time
so I think the era of
2020 to 2021 that was an ER of scaling
PR traing a lot both in at anic and at
openi and actually the first at that
time one of the first products was
GitHub compilot and I thought it was
completely interesting product the
autocomplete because it's so imp paining
the model has learned so much about the
code and the next token prediction for
The Code by the billions code tokens
using from GitHub open source projects
Etc and what has happened for the a
complete tap to top in the cursor or
gith Pilot is that the researchers
constrained VI rhf reinforcement
learning from Human feedback and
reinforcement learning from AI feedback
to make it extremely a little bit more
useful to use and this is where the era
of post training has gone off so in post
training we teach the model how to
complete function bodies understanding
dog strings how to complete generating
multi-line completions predicting the
next diffs apply the next diffs and I
think we are still in that era where
there is so much more to be explored in
the posttraining stage of rhf
rlaf to push the capabilities and models
to reason through complex code code
basis the next Paradigm in AI
research which has
happened last year
and and it was published by open a with
a new model 01 is scaling reinforcement
learning on Chain of Thought and this is
why we call them it's highly complex
reasoning and you can imagine you you
spend a lot more test time
comput on training in to scale
reinforcement learning and the reason
why it works is because the model learns
how to think during the training and
learn from the feedback by having really
good signals in
RL so on the left you can see the output
of normal GPD 40 or
gbd4 and on the right you can see the
entire Chain of Thought that has been
that the model has thought about to
solve the complex problems and as we
think about harder and harder tasks if
you want the model to go from you know
translation
towards solving medical problems you
actually need to spend you actually need
the model to like spend a lot of time
just thinking through the problem and
completely creating more complex
environments with tools and other other
tools and more complex environments to
think through and verify its outputs
during the Chain of Thought So as you
can see the chainnel thought itself is
very interesting and the model is has
certain words that it does um but um
there's a lot of science to be done in
terms of you know faithfulness in the
Chain of Thought how do we measure the
faithfulness what happens if the model
goes into like wrong direction can it
backtrack itself I think there was a lot
of science around that and we are only
the beginning of
it one of the first projects that I've
done at open a is actually how do
we the interaction Paradigm is very
different now so the interaction
Paradigm is models thinks a lot to solve
the problem if the problem is hard so
but how do we create this interaction
new interaction Paradigm with humans
such that it will be much easier so that
humans don't have to wait for 15 seconds
or 30 minutes for a model to come back
and one of the things that we did um as
a simple approach is to have like a
streaming models thoughts to a user and
that way we had to communicate what
exactly the summaries of the thoughts
for the model and communicate very
wisely to human but I think it's still
one of the design challenges like as the
model's capabilities and interraction
paradigms change you have like new
design challenges that you need to solve
um for these types of
models so and and I guess like this year
open is the year of agents and the way
we think about it is highly complex
reason such as models trained on a and
Chain of Thought using real world tools
such as browsing search computer use uh
over a long Horizon period of time over
a long
context but what's the next stage in my
view the next stage stage level is co-
innovators and the way I'm thinking
about is it's agents that is built upon
all the things that we've done with
reasoning and Tool use and long context
plus creativity and creativity is
enabled only through human AI
collaboration and I think this is where
I'm really really excited about in the
future is
to create new affordances for humans to
collaborate better with AI such that we
both can co-create the future that we
want and so those two scaling paradigms
in AI research has unlocked us new kind
of product research and you know you can
imagine product research being oh we
have API from the model and now we have
to integrate in the products but it's
actually what's happening on the ground
is we have like a very now we have like
a very nice rapid uation cycle of the
product development and and the reason
why is because we can use those highly
reasoning models to distill back to
smaller models or the models that we
canate very very fast and we can use
those highly complex reasoning models to
synthetically generate new data such
that we can create new post training new
data sets new reinforcement learning
environments so okay um so one of the
things that we can do is is creating new
completely new class of tasks and um you
know if the task is um how do we create
a multiplayer
collaboration uh with a human nii you
might want to simulate different users
and how do you do that you might want to
like synthetically generate data sets of
different users conditioned on the
different users and push chain on that
so it actually highly depends on like
what kind of product EXP experiences
that you want to create and extrapolate
that to a new class of tasks that you
want to P the
models um I think we are moving towards
more complex reinforcement learning
environments uh which means we can allow
models to use search or browsing or much
more collaborative tools like canvas
during ourl such that they can learn how
to be how to become better at
collaborating um we can love things like
in context learning I think models are
extremely extremely good so you can
essentially create something a new tool
and then the model will learn just by
few shot examples and this is extremely
rapid uation cycle for any
developer as I mentioned before
synthetic data wide distillation is
another thing I think we can also invent
New Model Behavior and interactions to
utilize user feedback so now we're going
to go through for some of the Vettes
that
um that has happened um from Anar toi um
I think the first concept that I've
learned um is how do you bring
unfamiliar capability into familiar from
factor and the reason why 100K context
uh was successful is because we found
you know file uploads is extremely
familiar from Factor everybody is
working on documents but you can imagine
we could have deployed 100 key content
text via infinite chats such that it's
like one huge long chat that you can
interact with but I think finding the
simplest form practice sometimes for
unfamiliar capability uh is one of the
design challenges uh in this new
era the next project that I worked uh
one the second project that I was I
worked on at open is called Chach tasks
um and actually I did not realize about
this until it was shipped um you know
reminders and tasks schedule tasks is
actually it's very familiar thing that
people do almost every day but what's
amazing about this product is that you
can scale this with new kind of
capabilities and the models so CHP task
is not just scheduled reminders and
to-do lists it's actually you can create
you can ask the model to continue the
story every day for you H or you can ask
the model model to
search everything that you are
interested in every day or every other
every other day so in a way you can also
like help yourself to like learn new
language by having like extremely
multimodal and interactive visualization
that CH can create and so I I think this
is concept of your product feature
should enable modular compositions that
will scale very nicely in the future as
the models will develop much higher
capability is um is one of the is is
something that I've learned by doing
chpt
tasks um I think another design
challenge that we have here is how do we
Bridge together real-time interaction
with models to a synchronous task
completion and where we can ask the
model to go off for like 10 hours to
research or write code and then come
back with the
solution and the bottleneck here is
trust and I believe
that giving trust can be solved by
giving humans new collaborative
ordinances to verify edit model outputs
and having them to give models realtime
feedback so that the model can self
improve and you know one of the first
products uh from antar was actually CLA
and slack and it was the first attempt
to have a virtual teammate in your
organization
and it was an amazing concept because
slack had all the affordances with tools
and image uploads and multiplayer
collaboration that you can
create and there is something in there
that is still I think there is still a
lot of things that we can do here and
take the lessons from clent slack to the
next generational products um again the
task was also like very much inspired by
cloud and slack prototypes when Claud
could just summarize channels slack
channels across the organization every
Friday and have a summaries for
everybody my first project at open was
canvas
and I thought that human collabary
affordances could scale and create new
creative capabilities and what I really
loved about the canvas and the way we
operate in canvas as a team is that it
was extremely flexible interface that we
could come up with and here here are
some like the vignettes that we had so
the canvas itself can become like
co-creator and co-editor and you can
have like a very very fine grain editing
uh interaction the model can also do
search in order to generate the report
and then you can also ask a question
back hi verify this output and you can
imagine this interface scales to
multiplayer when other people can join
your document or even multi-agents if I
can create a model critic or an editor
they can use you have like a multi-
agentic and multiplay collaboration at
the same time and so this is like a new
design challenge that we need to
navigate how do we do that I'm also
excited for personalized tutors I think
the models care are becoming extremely
multimodal extremely flexible that you
can learn new things in a new way the
way you like like if I'm a visual
learner and you are a more auditory
learner the model can adapt to your
personalization sorry um one thing that
uh I did yesterday is that
um I was on the plane and actually I
used canvas to create me a game and so I
really like this genor entertainment on
the
[Music]
Fly anyone can create their own tools
and VB apps now
and I'm not sure what the future will
look like but I think it will be
extremely amazing if a non a person who
never had to touch code ever before in
their life for the first time can create
the tool that they really wanted and
deploy that um for themselves or to
start a business from scratch and I
think there's something around pair
programming and code creators that we
can
use in order to create the future that
we want and so canvas has also become
mooo a PR programmer so the reason why
canvas is so flexible is because it was
ad it was trained both to become
collaborative for writing and
coding because it has tools such as
search and can search for AP
documentation it can become a data
scientist too and especially if you
upload the entire CSV docs um it can
generate a real time um
analysis and finally what I'm really
really excited what everybody is excited
in the ey is how do we
actually help models to become better at
research um and creating new
knowledge and here you can see that the
model that the model in the human can
co-create document or co-create a new
artifact that has never been happened
before so here's a demo of the paper
that I've co-published and then um I'm
asking the model to kind of reproduce it
and you can imagine this is like one of
the maybe one of the most common tasks
in research is to reproduce or you can
imagine reproduce like open source
GitHub repo and you you have like this
very nice Interactive
Paradigm where because the model can
also leverage its own internal
knowledge you and a you and a AI can
work together to come up with new
research hypotheses and verify certain
like research um directions together and
you can also handle delegate the tasks
to an AI assistant to do
that finally what are I'm really excited
about the future is that there will be
this layer of invisible software
creation for all um and especially what
I'm really excited is like from the
mobile itself people can just create
their own software
tools I think the way you interact with
AI fundamentally changes in a way that
the way you access the internet will
also change my prediction is that you
will click less and less on the internet
links and the way you will access the
internet will be why models lens which
will be much cleaner and in a much more
personalized way and uh you can imagine
have like very personalized multimodel
outputs let's say if I say I want to
learn more about the solar system
instead of it giving me a text output it
should give you a 3Gs interactive
visualization of the solar system and
you can have like highly richly
interactive features to learn more and I
think there is there'll be this like
kind of cool future of like generator
entertainment on the
Fly for the people to learn and share
new games with other
people I think the way I'm thinking
about it is the kind of interface to AI
is is blank canvas that kind of self
mores into your intent so for example
you come to the work today and your
intention is to just write code then the
canvas becomes more of an IDE like a
cursor or like a coding IDE although the
future programming might change or if
you're a writer and you decided to write
a Noel together the model can start
creating tools on the Fly for you such
that it will be much easier for you to
brainstorm or edit the writing or create
character plots and
visualize the structure of the plot
itself and finally I think the
co-innovation is actually going to
happen with co-direction creative
c-direction with the models itself and
it's through
collaboration with highly reasoning
agenda systems uh that will be extremely
capable of superum tasks to create new
novels films games uh and essentially
new science new knowledge
creation cool um um thank you so much I
think that's the end of my talk um
[Music]